الاخبار اهلا بكم قال حكيم ومقاطعه
الروسيه ان اربعه اشخاص يصيبوا في قصف
اوكراني على شبشينكو وانه تم اجلاء
مناطق اخرى لو اعلن حاكم اقليم كريسنو دار
الروسيه حريقا في مصفاه
لتكرير النفط في الاقليم نتيجته هجوم
بمسيره اوكرانيه وافاد الحاكم في قناه على
تيليجرام انه تمت السيطره على الحريق وتم
اخماده بالفعل مشيرا الى انه لم تسجل اي
اصابات
اصيب عشرته فلسطينيين بالرصاص المعدني
المغلف بالمطاط والحجاره والعشرات بحالات
اختناق بالغاز المسير للدموع خلال هجوم
للمستوطنين على منازل الفلسطينيين في بلده
جلوا جنوبيا نابلس اقل غسان دغلس مسؤول
ملف الاستيطان في شمال الضفه الغربيه ان
مستوطنين هاجموا منازل الفلسطينيين في
المنطقه الشرقيه من البلده ليله الماضيه
بحمايه جيش الاحتلال الامر الذي ادى
لاندلاع مواجهات في المنطقه
تعقد الاليه الموسعه بشان الازمه
السودانيه اجتماعها الاول في هذا الصبابه
اليوم بموجب قرار قمه مجلس السلم والامن
الافريقيه التي عقدت السبت الماضي وكشف
مصدر دبلوماسي للجزيره احدى 21 دوله الى
جانب الاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمات الايجاد
والجامعه العربيه والاتحاد الاوروبي
والامم المتحده
سيتشاركون في الاجتماع واكد المصدر ان
الاجتماع سيضع اليات لتنسيق الدعم للسودان
وتامين وقف فوري ودائم وشامل وغير مشروط
للاعمال العدائيه
اعلنت كوريا الشماليه ان صاروخا فضائيا
يحمل قمرا صناعيا للاستطلاع العسكريه
اطلقته صباح الاربعاء تحطم في البحر بسبب
خلل فني وقالت وكاله الانباء المركزيه
الكوريه الشماليه ان اطلاق الصاروخ الجديد
شولم واحد فشل بسبب عدم استقرار المحرك
ونظام الوقود في الصاروخ وقد نشر الجيش
الكوريه الجنوبي صورا قال انها لحطام
الصاروخ الفضائي الكوريه الشمالي
وقدانا البيت الابيض اطلاق كوريا الشماليه
قمرا صناعيا باستخدام تكنولوجيا صواريخ
الباليسيه كما دانت اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه تجربه
ونقلت رويترز عن الخارجيه اليابانيه ان
اطلاق بيونج لصاروخ باليسي يمثل انتهاك
للعقوبات الدوليه من الامين العام الامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتي كوريا الشماليه قمرا
عسكريا باستخدام تكنولوجيا صواريخ
الباليستيه
قال الرئيس الصيني خلال الاجتماع دوريه
للجنه للجنه المركزيه للحزب الشيوعي مساء
امس ان وضع الامن القومي الصيني معقد
وخطير وفق ما نقلت صحيفه الشعب اليوميه
الرسميه ياتي هذا بعد تصريح للمتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الصينيه الجمعه الماضيه بشان
تقارير عن خطط امريكيه لشن هجمات
الكترونيه تستهدف البنيه التحتيه الحيويه
للصين
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]